CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend was homeland
security and counterterrorism adviser
president george w bush fran good
morning morning a couple of important
questions here according to his alleged
manifesto he'd been planning this for
years he was practicing at a gun range
how was he not on law enforcement or
intelligence radar well you know if he
doesn't have a prior criminal history or
no one has tip to law enforcement it's
very it's sort of the needle in the
haystack problem don't go back now and I
think what you're gonna find is whether
it's internet searches a whole bunch of
sort of things if they had known about
it would have tipped them but the
problem is again unless there's an
informant or a criminal history or some
sort of call to law enforcement
attention it's possible he was planning
it and they wouldn't have known and he
clearly wanted to be seen and noticed
around the world which is why he
live-streamed the massacre you've said
that you think it's time for these
social media companies to maybe delay
live streaming of videos that's that's
right so as you know here at networks
and cable we're required by the FTC to
have that capability to cut the feed if
it's too violent if it's bad words that
we're not allowed to say on the air and
that social media companies got a
legislative exemption from that and I
think it's time if they can't delay it
then either they shouldn't provide the
feed or they don't have the capability
to delay it do you think it's feasible
for Congress to act on it I do think so
and I think they ought to consider the
notion that any portion of the 17
minutes and they've done a real job at
taking it down but as we all know once
it's out there on the Internet it's
almost forever even though there's our
Appeals please don't show it please
don't show up there's always somebody
that will show it do you also think it's
a question again about soft targets do
we need to re-evaluate those well as you
know we live always after the fact
you'll see a greater police presence at
places of worship DHS the Department of
Homeland Security is now doing active
shooter training at soft targets but you
know you say to yourself it's a sad
world we live in we have to do that but
I think we we have to be conscious these
attacks are on the rise we know that I
want to turn to a different subject this
was covered on 60 minutes last night
this mysterious illness that has been
defecting some of our diplomats
abroad specifically American officials
spoke for the first time about some what
they call brain damage while they were
in China and Robin Garfield who was a
trade officer told this just got Pelle
last night let's take a listen I was
sitting next to Robin and something I
felt like hit me from the left side and
at first it felt like an electric shock
and then it paralyzed me so I was not
able to move or speak it hit you so hard
you felt like you were in danger in the
room yes they say the children suffered
blurred vision and loss of balance your
daughter was literally falling down yes
she fell down multiple times that day we
went on a walk and she just fell on her
face it was very abnormal she never does
that and then a second time she
completely lost her balance and just
fell to the side that was Robin Garfield
and his wife why isn't the State
Department calling this an attack it's a
good question or I think there's there
continues to be a debate inside the
intelligence community about the cause
of these injuries but it's it it's
undeniable that both diplomats in Cuba
and in China have suffered as a result
of this look I we don't know what's
being said behind the scenes oftentimes
diplomatically these issues will be
raised and certainly in the case of Cuba
there's been a chilling of relations
over it yeah they talked about a
microwave system that it's that I want
people to be clear about what's
happening because I watched it last
night
thinking this is so frightening so they
put out microwaves in your apartment
they were saying that affects your brain
gives you serious brain injury and all
sorts of different ailments how common
is that technology I've never really
heard of it until recently so going back
to the 70s at least a scientist by the
name of dr. Frey identified this and
said it can affect your hearing this is
different than the microwave where we
warm coffee yes this is a very directed
energy sort of thing but we knew back in
the 70s not only did the United States
understand what this was the Russians
did as well we suspect the Chinese have
the capability and other
other of our allies in Europe so it's
not an uncommon capability but it can
have the effects that are being
described do you think the State
Department's doing enough about it
well I you know it's hard to say again
we don't know what's going on behind the
scenes but you sure hope that these
these diplomats are getting the kind of
attention and healthy who's very scary
stuff Thank You Fran always good to have
you here